welcome to PMT ot on Yahoo Sports Peter
King Mike Florio talking big stories in
the National Football League and one of
the guys who is in the shortlist of MVP
candidates this year second-year
quarterback lamar jackson the last of
five quarterbacks taken in round one in
2018 now the best of the bunch so far in
2019 Peter why did the Marv Jackson make
it all the way to pick number 32 in
April of 2018 because I think evaluators
in the NFL were concerned that he was so
much that so much of his game was based
around the running game and look right
now and I love Lamar Jackson and I love
the way he plays and I think you take
Lamar Jackson in the way he plays and
you take the risk of him getting hurt
and I understand everybody is screaming
about that I was talking to Mike
Tannenbaum the former GM this week and
he was talking about how he likes Justin
Herbert of Oregon coming out in the
draft he's kind of year your standard
you know sort of Roethlisberger almost
pocket type even though Roethlisberger
can move around a little bit but this is
your classic NFL quarterback oh you know
in history a guy who will stay in the
pocket and and my point was well what
about what you're all what you're seeing
with all of these guys at the top of
their game Russell Wilson he moves Lamar
Jackson he moves deshaun Watson he moves
Patric mahomes he moves and and so many
of the top guys right now are very
mobile in and around the pocket and that
was the argument as I recall with Lamar
Jackson and and even Bill Polian said
maybe they ought to think about moving
on into wide receiver very famous moment
at that combine Lamar Jackson said I'm
not working out at any other position
and good for him and I'll tell you the
one thing that he has shown Mike both
against New England and against
Cincinnati he may not have the classic
quarterback throwing mechanics but he
throws a beautiful
football and he made some huge throws in
both weeks and in my opinion it's
everybody's loss around the NFL when
Josh Rosen gets picked 22 picks ahead of
Lamar Jackson that shows me that there's
a lot of people in the NFL who do not
have a forward looking lean and
assessing the quarterback position you
know the big question for me was can he
do at the NFL level the things that he
did while he was at Louisville he was so
phenomenal running the ball and throwing
the ball and he even had statistically a
better season the year after he won the
Heisman his team just wasn't good enough
for him to be back in the equation for a
second straight Heisman Trophy but he
was great
can he take that to the next level and
the Ravens saw something the Ravens had
that belief in the perfect storm lined
up for them because they were ready to
move on from Joe Flacco they were ready
to find another quarterback and they
were sitting there at 16 after four
others had gone and as I heard a time
owner Steve bisciotti was banging the
drum let's take him now let's take him
now they played that board perfectly
they trade from 16 down to 25 and take
Hayden Hurst the tight end swoop back
into 32 in a trade with the Eagles and
get Lamar Jackson and they were thrilled
and they've been spending most of their
time ever since then Peter coming up
with the right way to use him and it I
don't say that it's necessarily
revolutionized the game but it's
different than what we've seen and I
think it's the next step in the
evolution of football coaches at the NFL
level realizing that when you see a
quarterback you like at the college
level you have to bring what he does and
the offense he runs with him if you do
that it'll work if you try to jam him
into your system it may not work and I
think coaches are warming up to the idea
of bringing not just the player but
everything the player does up to the
next level and seeing if he can do it
there Mike I think you mentioned
something in your last in your last
paragraph or so that's really important
and cannot be forgotten one of the
things that the Ravens wanted to do was
to challenge Joe Flacco who had gotten a
little bit stale in Baltimore they
wanted to challenge Flacco and the
Flocka wins the job great but they
wanted to put a little press
Sharan him to be better to work harder
and at that moment when they took Lamar
Jackson that energized not only the
quarterback room but the entire
organization and look at where they are
right now they are arguably the best
team in the NFL now that the 49ers have
lost and we'll see where they go from
here check out more PFT ot on Yahoo
Sports
throughout the season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports